[Music]
foreign
what's up my little brother
what's up
your hour
yeah you're flying back out to Montreal
my brother
yeah I'm going today shows tonight so
you got you this you're up there for
three weeks it's always your feet on the
line by the way if everybody's wondering
everybody you mind your business what
was last weekend the last weekend was
the dirty show
is
and then um did you say slate
Clayton yeah how was he
it's all right he's worried about his
future he's really worried did you talk
what am I supposed to do did you torch
them a little bit
uh I started a torture but then he
always started he knows me right now
he's like he's like you know Tom
like uh I tried I was like you know a
little bit now you're you're just a
pothead I know now
okay I'm so good oh I I still you know
what he tried to friend me on Facebook
me and Ralphie were sitting here Ralphie
[__] did the podcast and let the cat
out of the bag on the podcast how I used
to torture him and [__] and somebody
else asked me about it how I used to
tell him I put it under his [__] milk
container and he'd say where the [__] is
it I don't know it's under your milk
container Jesus Christ my daughter stole
it and he thought about that
you're the first time I read it was so
great when you told them like hey Ari
Ari uh Ari doesn't love blow he's got a
package coming for him he was friendly
with me and he was extra he looked at me
all over here he said where you're going
like nothing like I just gotta sometimes
I gotta meet but oh are you gonna meet
him later
here's the difference man calm down you
get so into it oh he's uh he's a great
guy man a lot the reason why I want to
have you on today is because
I've been in What's called the conundrum
the last couple weeks uh because you
have uh this is not happening now but
it's going from the internet to prime
time TV on Comedy Central
prime time TV yeah 11 o'clock at night
Prime [__] time brother this is a
show that started for five bucks at the
[__] improv back room on a Tuesday
night the first one at Thursday nights
me Mark Maron remember we all did that
[__] one show over there
yeah yeah
Steve AG yeah we all that's when I told
the Pink Floyd thing but it's so weird
that
it all started and now it's on
television and you called me I'm gonna
do one of the episodes in September at
the cheetah we're going back to the
cheetah
and it's so weird this this writing uh
this writing [__] uh
process
has just been I don't know Ari this has
really changed me
well it's kind of fun to be like uh
sort of think about those things
sometimes I don't even think about those
times until I until I get a topic and
then I start like wondering what
happened I called my high school friends
sometimes I was like hey was I ever get
into it you know
remember the topic is anything happening
on my memory and then remind me of
stories I'm like oh yeah
oh yeah we stopped our kids toothbrush
up her ass that's right
whatever it was
just wanted to relive those days and
stuff and it's so funny like whenever I
do those things I usually think about it
I make little notes and then I make
calls
I'll try to call people who were around
me at that time and I go remember that
time and they'll go yeah didn't you
[__] whatever like I called my uncle
uh because I want to get the whole
funeral thing
you know I call my uncle and we talk for
like an hour and he was like let me tell
you something oh my [__] 74 years I
never saw a crazy a funeral than your
mother's
and that's what happened he goes do you
remember the first night
and I go no and he goes you know the
first night with zaraida how she had the
[__] owner by the neck and three
people had to break him apart and I go
oh my God yeah that's right there was it
was the opening night all white people
came to that one
that was the all-white one like
everybody from the neighborhood came
their parents the kids from the
neighborhood I was never so embarrassed
in my life Harry
because because Zoraida didn't go off on
the afternoon one you know they usually
have a two to four viewing then they
have uh uh you know a four to seven or
six to nine
a Cuban rake is 24 hours
for five days because that's how I did
them in the Old Country you put the body
in your house and people just came to
your house
but if I can
like dictator yeah like in your living
room in the old days when you died there
was no funeral parlors they put you in a
casket and they put you in the living
room and then people came over and they
drank and they and they whatever they
did they pissed on you and they went
[__] home no big deal
so they wanted that he wanted to have
that same Cuban feeling in this Cuban
Funeral Parlor it's called Rivero
Funeral Parlor still in North Bergen
it's a different owner though like I
made millions and got the [__] out of it
and I'll never forget that the first day
at the funeral man not the two to four
one but the seven and nine
yeah I'm a young kid I'm still in shock
that my mother died I'm having a
conversation with some kids about
basketball and all of a sudden I'm
hearing in Spanish
that means [__] your mother I'm gonna
kill you and [__] and I go in the other
room and say right it's got the [__]
owner by the throat and there's three
people and she's pointing at him and
she's yelling at him and I go what's
going on and and she told me that she my
mother didn't have the right dress on
I remember thinking about that going who
gives a [__] she's dead
do you think she's worried about what
dress she's got she's [__] dead
you know but just and I know my uncle
saying that there was a they did like
some Santeria stuff the first day at the
the funeral I didn't remember this
either and he goes to the day they
buried and they still hadn't cleaned
that water up and that the water tipped
over in the jar and the limousine and at
the limousine Drive I do remember that
pulled over and couldn't drive because
the water it was the Santeria water
filled yeah the Santeria water had like
chicken blood in it and all this goat
blood and [__] they had killed all these
animals and it was in there mixed with
feathers and [__] and the [__] thing
that you're supposed to throw in the
hole and the thing tipped over and the
[__] limo smelled like gas the limo
driver had to pull over he couldn't
drive he kept puking this was [__]
the funeral from [__] hell people
were drinking people were doing blow I
don't know the first time they ripped
out like a ball of pinch because my
mother drank pinch so they ripped out a
bottle of pinch which is like a whiskey
and the funeral Paula was like eyes you
cannot drink at my funeral
I will lose my license and they've just
looked at them like you better get back
in that [__] room we're gonna drink
so all these things I got from my uncle
I remembered the I remembered the one
night that was the night that always
stayed with me but back back to what
we're talking about here it's just
amazing Ari what you've done with this
because I don't worry about [__] I
usually when I write a joke I write a
joke and I put it out there where they
like it or not it's a joke to me and
just by the sound of it you know whether
you're going to keep it or not you know
yeah uh this is something that we get to
put out one time we really get depressed
exactly one time pretty much and then
you're done and then you're done you get
to practice it a little bit you know but
not really because people look at your
wheel like we're at a comedy show why
are you telling me about your dead
[__] mother
you've been working a lot of
conversations but it gets weird
sometimes yeah I tried doing it the
other night people were like where the
[__] are we going with this [__] Joey
so I'm gonna have to have Leah take me
in the [__] here and we'll send it to
you and see what you think but it's just
really weird all right man it's just uh
I like riding pretty cool isn't it
[__] 12 people in the audience
come over to TV
with no booze
it's traffic there's no booze in there
you couldn't bring booze in yeah the
first two or three of them we had no
booze and then after that you put a name
on it somebody showed up and you moved
it to the big room and there was no
looking back after that
yeah they were getting mad because the
lineup is so good and they were like why
do you have [__] Joey Diaz and Bill
Burr
and Jim Jefferies in this in the little
side of them for five dollars I'm like I
don't know what's the room you gave me
because you gave me a small room
they're gonna do that yeah
when you write some of these stories
when you're thinking about some of these
stories like your sex ones
do you [__] get [__] up for a few
days like that you did these things like
I always do
yeah sometimes sometimes I just know it
I have trouble sometimes with an ending
like like uh
like title together
and like you know there's no real
beginning or ending to a story I mean
like like even that funeral it's like it
doesn't begin at the funeral it begins
you and your mom were were close you
know it begins way before so it's like
at what point do you start at what point
do you end it
um
they're cool like learning the process
even from watching other Comics too you
learn a lot
you know I watched all the series I
watched Rogan and I watched uh
uh Moshe Kashi I watch I don't even know
some of the [__] names
and it's really interesting
it's really interesting the different
styles of Storytelling there are also
you have to chase completed and you are
yeah but then you know other people TJ
or whoever Sean Patton yeah it's cool
it's like there's no right way for
people just do it however do you go back
the same way you write jokes
like the same process when you sit down
and write a joke is it the same like the
same way you go right let's write a
story
because the point of it isn't to be
funny like in a way I don't know if it's
a different process
yeah it's less it's like it's like it's
like uh it's like um you know Annie Hall
is a comedy but it's not as many jokes
as [__] Happy Gilmore okay you know
so it's like it's slower
but um
yeah so you don't take as much of a
comment because let's be serious moments
and it can be like I could plot you have
to do set up you can't just do a punch
line every every five seconds
set some stuff up but people will go
with it the first time I saw one really
good was Ralphie May I was working the
cover booth in in the or The Comedy
Store
and uh and it was a shitty night
nobody's doing that well and uh and
Ralphie May was on time for like three
minutes four minutes and goes you know
what you guys not an a audience you're
not getting my eight jokes he's my djos
and then he started doing some story
about the first time I met Sam Kinison I
won some contest when he was a 17 year
old
and character was doing key bumps in
front of him and the 17 year old like
what the [__] he didn't know was
happening and then I'll tell you you can
watch when I covered with everybody was
on the edge of their seat
you know like interested in what he was
saying it might not have been like as
funny as Ralphie usually is like punch
punch punch but man it was interesting
you get everyone's attention in a
certain way I was in the I went to that
movie today I was in the bathroom this
old guy next to me farted at the urinal
and like when I was like 10 I was in the
bathroom with my best friend yeah in
Wendy's this old guy farted and we both
died laughing we ran into the parking
lot he saw it
and I saw and this guy farted next to me
in the Euro at the movie theater today
and it took all my strength
it's [__] crazy it's funny when you
fart like I blast with a fart in the
bathroom airport bathroom and about a
month ago everybody freaked out like
everybody it was a long one I was at the
urinal at the end of the P yeah when
you're [__] Uranus you're tightening
it up and [__] and I blasted one a long
one
and people looked at me I thought that's
what you blasted farts well I guess not
I guess oh my I guess you gotta blast
them in public I did one in the bathroom
this weekend and Paula started laughing
because my bedroom's not that far from
my bathroom I didn't have this big fart
and she just started laughing and stuff
like that's pretty cool what else you do
all weekend not much we uh we had
her mom's birthday dinner and then uh we
picked her up Saturday and went to the
gym watching TV watch Patriot Sunday
they win yeah everybody happy Bill
Belichick good yeah that's good I mean I
was just I was worried because the bills
I was worried we're gonna lose but it
looks it looks like we're getting better
beautiful the bills the bill the bills
were doing pretty well and we were tied
for first what yeah it's only six games
into the season yeah get them started
he's a Cowboy fan you know he's got
binoculars Ortiz has statistical cancer
yeah
now who the Cowboys beat up on Seattle
Seahawks they smacked they went right at
[__] Sherman they took it to him they
played like men that's how you do it
yeah a couple freak plays a punk got
blocked for a touchdown and
something else happened some fun before
a touchdown
and they still came right back and
[__] last minute drive Romo wasn't
Romo
amazing five and one they're gonna make
the playoffs man the first I was done I
thought six and ten this year
look at you look at the boat they're
gonna break my heart again they're gonna
break my [__] heart again week 17
like they always do unbelievable I of
course went to Denver
the uh The Improv very nice very nice
nice people I want to thank everybody
that came out had a great time metal
Brad 420 brought us this [__] the
blunt of death Graham blunt to death
which we're gonna spark up
after the show tonight all Alien OG and
make a video of by the time Lee will be
passed out oh yeah like the girl in 16
Candles I had three quarters of an
animal of a Barney today so well you're
going deep tonight we need some milk
with this what [__] milk
no smoking bringing up milk to Joey is
like bringing up ranch dressing why no
chocolate milk how about chocolate milk
I love chocolate milk let's get some
chocolate milk and car throws yeah we're
gonna get chocolate milk 7-Eleven no
there's no seven running around yeah
we're dead there's 7-Eleven everywhere
what this looks like Bodega Ville out
here there's no someone around here
there's some 11 10 blocks that way oh
yeah Laurel Canyon oh yeah but though
there's one off of Burbank
yeah you know there's no 7-Elevens in
Dayton Ohio how come I don't know
because I can't support it it can't
support there's no 7-Elevens in all of
Dayton the closest one is [__]
Columbus where'd you fly out of Dayton
or they have a local airport yeah
International Airport tremendous no
Denver was very nice taking Flyers
that's where [__] Wright brothers
were after North Carolina or something I
don't know I look at the pictures you
learn something new every day for the
pictures at the airport Denver was very
nice I was very impressed with it it was
uh I hadn't been there to do comedy in a
long time like that like by myself just
how long a decade
94. wow 20 years 96 was the last I went
into the triple run I did Craig I did uh
Craig
somewhere up close to Aspen and whatever
was Saturday night that's the last time
I was I was dating a girl named Carol
the one I found the aluminum foil in her
ass over there
and I [__] said to go with me that
was a nightmare it was a [__]
nightmare I'm sure she loves it that's
how you remember her I still got it in
there and she's getting married she's
actually faster two weeks ago so let me
ask you something does he know how many
dicks you saw and she's like no I mean
he's not gonna know okay he thinks like
your breath is [__] minty cause
that's gum he doesn't know that that's
[__] you probably got [__]
testicular [__] nut sack canceling
your mouth it tastes like [__]
peppermint juice or whatever
you guys
there's certain places that you go to
yeah like Ari and I went to Denver one
time uh-huh first thing we did was we
walked around the corner and we got
green chili yeah at that place oh yeah
that's it that's it listen that's it
that's it for Denver you don't go to
Denver to get a steak or a cheeseburger
well they have an Italian hero listen
stop it stop it you walk into a place
you look at the menu if they got the
pork green chili soup you walk in there
and you go let me get a [__] cup of
soup don't ask if it's spicy don't ask
just bring extra tortillas and then you
decide if it's good bring the cup if the
cup is good then go all out then get
whatever you want but you're going to
smother it with the green chili just
it'll be good yes so the first thing I
did was because they have what people
don't know or some people do know is
that they have different kind of Mexican
foods
the food you get in San Diego is
different than the food you got in La
yeah but it's completely different than
the food you get in the southwest Dallas
no uh New Mexico New Mexico uh Colorado
Utah Santa Fe Santa Fe that's what they
have they have green chili when you go
to Texas it's Tex-Mex chewies
oh yeah all that week the queso and all
that stuff so you have three different
areas maybe even four I don't know what
the other might one might be Don Carlos
was talking about that I said it's some
truck went by and said authentic Mexican
food it goes dang authentic Mexican food
he goes there ain't any authentic
Mexican food I make [__] San Diego
garbage Mexican food that's what that
guy makes too he's like be honest about
it Americanized
but they still have there's a lot of
things that are very today you know uh
uh tacos a [__] tacos but they [__]
it up in the east coast I've never I
like hard shell they're no they're not
bad I'm just saying it's not the same
and like when I moved here I had never
tried like a taco with cilantro and
onion my my mom made like no I can't
deal with it no no no no no no East
Coast hasn't had [__] Mexican food
since Jesus left I know it's so weird
it's horrible because they didn't
migrate and even the ones that migrate
the good Mexican food in the east coast
you have to pay for it it's [__] it's
1995 a dish for like you know two
enchiladas and a and a bean taco and
North and North Bergen has one I grew up
I'm not bringing it used to be Gregory
seven waste and they have an upscale one
in Fort Lee which is a tequila bar but
my friends go and they're like bro we
dropped 60 80 bucks every time we go in
there I don't understand that I was
telling Paula last night we were walking
by this place on Ventura and it was like
a fancy Mexican place and the best
Mexican food are tacos
garbage food at its heart it's garbage
food so don't [__] doll it up too
much just eat it as it is but there's
good [__] Mexican yeah yeah there's
good and bad but yeah I like the stuff
in San Diego the stuff by The Comedy
Store the the rosary is by the Denny's
right by PB the bar yeah right across
that [__] behind that it's open 24 hours
what's the place on Western it's so good
oh the restaurant yeah it's a restaurant
yeah
the one on Western is the one El Cholo
and that place is good walk right at
your table the spicy guacamole [__] and
the margarita is there yeah I used to
play them and Josh Wolf used to cater
for them and the main thing wasn't the
money was to take a gallon of those
margaritas you always told the help we
were out of margaritas but we ordered
three gallons they're out these
[__] drink like fish and hit me
meanwhile you got one in the trunk when
you poked up a gallon of that [__]
Margarita juice that they have down
there was it hot though I'm in the trunk
who gets a [__] you put on Ice in an
hour you're taking an hour I know but
still no you just put in the car and you
[__] leave it back there you cater at
night come on use your [__] head I've
never catered yeah so you put the
[__] thing in the truck they have ice
in there from the catering you can tell
them whatever the [__] you want it's
we're all out let me see all three of
them okay whatever
so we take the [__] gallon homeless
and those margaritas are delicious and
they will [__] you up
so if you're a margarita fan you're a
Mexican food fan El Cholo in on Western
Boulevard Western delicious
yeah yeah it's not that bad it's not
that it's not that pricey no it's only
like 12 13. that's it you have a great
time it's authentic as [__] they have
the blue corn tortillas or whatever the
blue tortillas one like two months a
year
it's a good date place too
yeah the Margaritas in Boulder it was a
place that you had three margaritas and
they cut you off because they made them
with green alcohol what so you didn't
even taste the [__] the grain alcohol
and next you know Papa
[__] delicious and at lunch time they
had dollar Margaritas little ones so
people go in there and get [__] lit I
used to go and eat the black beans were
the best in there they had a mix of like
refried beans really just just delicious
but all that stuff is you're right it's
not authentic we've it's like a chalupa
ask a Mexican what a chalupa is and
he'll look at you and go I have no idea
right because they didn't invent that's
something it's like ciabatta bread
that's not Italian that's something
that's some [__] Gentile so let's
let's be different really yeah
[__] about ciabatta bread well they
may call it something else but that's
that's garbage I hate that [__] I hate
your mother really yeah I love it you
know I heard Sushi's not that huge in
Japan like I heard that's like not like
that I always said Japan it's different
like in Japan it's like [__] like
dirty birds and [__] you eat dust and
seeds and seek clams and [__] and you
[__] the fish has been stabbed and
they throw it back in the water yeah so
you see where the knife wound was [__]
like that
you know [__] like that that's what it's
different but it's freshly This was
later what was this reinvention Sergeant
Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band what
was that supposed to be about I have no
[__] idea it was so long ago but the
cover is tremendous yeah so much in
there the cover is tremendous I got the
flowers and the shape like a guitar and
it says Paul's dead oh it says remember
they've played the whole trick from the
United States Paul McCartney was dead in
these [__] saps fell for it but it
was tremendous marketing yeah they
didn't know at the time that was the
most brilliant marketing they had ever
[__] ran they play Iron The Walrus
backwards and it says all that crazy I
just started getting vinyls and a couple
of them had really cool like artwork and
then I got a Steve Martin one that had a
setlist in the on the back it was pretty
cool I never had anybody said this
that's a cool thing to put on here it
was a photocopied setlist on like a car
on the back of like a cardboard uh
headshot it was pretty cool yeah someone
got me one and it's like kind of a thing
now like to get back in the vinyl but
somebody got me vinyl so I got it Bill
Cosby with the pill in it
I got a whole bunch of Cosby albums for
uh Steve Simone got me gift and got me a
whole bunch album
I wonder if they're uh
I wonder if any of the sets of the
Spanish Fly sets that's gonna be [__]
up if it is he does do a setup on
Spanish Fly I mean I remember hearing
about that in Camp but the when you see
him say it now after all that stuff is
out like Larry King you're like
Spanish Fly that was big when I was
going to fly I was big I don't even know
if it worked the guy left spanish fly in
his glove compartment he went into the
grocery store his girlfriend found it
drink some found it came back she was
dead humping the [__]
stick shift my friend the oceans he gave
it to his grandmother to see if it works
we all chipped him we gave him like five
dollars and he gave it to his grandma
poisoned your friend's grandmother not
me he poisoned his own grass didn't
poison set her free he just set that
[__] free as [__] he's in fact it's his
birthday today Mike Olson he's 54. I
seen it on Facebook so what's happening
you bad [__] a beautiful day to
be alive I had a very [__]
interesting evening weekend evening had
a great uh morning I went I had fungi I
still got fun going with my toenail so I
think we got lasered [__] beamed off
if you got fungi under your toenail go
get a laser beamed off of this [__]
instrument everybody wants to live in
the future here's your [__] chance
they shoot laser beams right in your
toes they get a hose with like water
with ice in it and they condense it I
don't know what the [__] they do when
they blow it on your toes to freeze them
then they beam it because it gets hot
every once in a while you're like ah and
it burns and you could smell your fungus
and your toenail frying in the [__]
hand it's only 10 minutes today I gotta
go next Monday and the Monday after that
I'm gonna rub some [__] money when
you start getting fungus in your toes
yeah 10 years ago and then what does it
do it pushes your toenail out and the
fungi develops underneath and then so
what is it fun you ever see people that
have a [__] [__] up Funk uh toenail
and hangs over when you go to the pool
yeah oh yeah that's what it looks like I
cut it I keep it good and I paint it I
try the Swahili in a jiu jitsu I put a
[__] Band-Aid on it but it always
falls off paint it and people see that
[__] infested [__] toenail
I would give somebody a 50 to sniff it
just sniff that [__] away put
that big old toe in just thinking
nostril and take a big old [__] like
it was a liquor sniff does it smell yes
it smells it doesn't smell like you
don't smell in the air but sometimes
native late at night I'll cut the
toenail underneath it smells yeah
underneath it smells harm when you let
that it's like a toe jam but a little
tougher and you spin it around your
finger and then you put that ball on
your counter yeah you wake up no more
you smell that ball you almost [__]
die that's disgusting male [__]
sometimes I'll do that I'll dig
underneath the toenail like like off
here and then I'll dig if that's a
toenail like under like that and then
smell what's left
oh it's horrible twit that we're Lively
people know I'll tweet them I don't know
I forgotten [__] welcome to the Church
of beautiful I did something this
weekend that was completely out of my
[__] character I drove two hours to
jiu jitsu tournament two hours I'm the
five perfect on a Saturday to watch one
yeah at three o'clock and he had two in
the afternoon I decided me I thought you
were joking no man you know I don't do
much and and people come to the shows
and stuff and I always feel guilty that
I don't to go to enough things like yeah
like how could at this point in my life
good afternoon for a basketball game or
football game you went through a Lego
game watch a Laker game you know you
experienced it but I can't go watch
stand up or right improv comedy I'll go
watch a play if somebody knows of a good
play in Hollywood you know what I
thought of on the way here
go see that Angela Lansbury play I
wonder if she's still good I heard she's
working really good down on the I mean
she's been an actor for 75 years it's
right there right on the probably
somewhere around there probably tickets
on expense I want to see if you can get
better with you when you're that older
yeah yeah they say it's a great they're
Pantages the Fantasia it's the Pantages
to the cross from the W there it's a
great [__] Hey listen bro the older
they get the better they get I wonder if
they skip they stay sharp at their 70s
they could be a [__] Powerhouse
murder Spirit was in like she was old
then and that was a long time ago how is
she still alive
those people take care of themselves
what do you think Lee how was your
weekend I agree with yourself they had
did you see uh Billy Crystal's new thing
it's not like it's like it's like a
one-man comedians on comedians or
something no well no yeah they give them
a new show which that's probably gonna
be terrible but his HBO special like 300
Sundays or whatever yeah with his dad it
was like half stand up half one-man show
with like pictures and stuff it was
pretty cool yeah
no left not again no it had laughs I
mean his entire audience is old is like
90 90 years old really Crystal has a
precise audience my mom loves him older
Jews and they go and that's their pride
and joy really they dress up they spend
a little bit they even take an extra 20
out of the ATM yeah they live it up with
Billy Chris there's just some Jews that
Jews go out for and live it up like they
make the Jews proud and you don't know
until you go like I see it because I'm a
non-jew so when I go like when I went to
see Bette Midler I went to see Bette
Midler in 30 years how is she phenomenal
Bette Midler do three hours to do stand
up she'll sing she'll dance but it was
filled with Jews who for that night they
forgot they would that was the Super
Bowl yeah like you could tell they were
very nice you know they won't smoke pot
or nothing but they'll Giggle and
they'll turn their head they'll smile
and even the men will loosen up a little
bit like holy [__] one of the first
non-animated kids movies like when I was
a kid one of the first movie like actual
adult movies I saw was Mr Saturday night
my Dad loved them we had um
yeah When Harry Met Sally he was massive
I forgot about that he just seems like a
husband okay what how has he ever in the
movie that uh isn't bad when he plays a
cop I don't know with another black guy
with this the dancer he plays a cop and
they [__] it's a Chicago movie
they're like Chicago cops he did that
like in the 80s Billy Crystal's been uh
doing with the Cowboys City Slickers
silly slick City this is really good
yeah he made some good money he did some
good [__] Billy Crystal City Slickers
Herman Sally there were some really good
movies he was in huh my giant oh forget
it but at least it was that well 300
Sundays is about him
you know it's like a poor man's Woody
Allen though I always thought was that
just like
the actor version I never got to see any
of Woody Allen stand up was he funny I
don't know it hurts an album I have no
idea I think so but I don't know he was
like dead banished yeah deadpan you know
like very like uh well they all wanted
to be the crazy Jew
what's the current time at home who's
the crazy joke from the 60s the reason
why we're here Lenny Bruce if you watch
that the one I always talk to you like
the black and white one that's one of my
favorite pieces of stand up yeah yeah
man because uh I never seen any of that
is it good yeah it is good you catch it
and you're like damn
look at this [__] crazy yeah he
was Jazzy he had a great Rhythm to it
cool but that was interesting I had
never been to a Jujitsu tournament
before oh yeah I'll tell you what the
most interesting thing was about it what
that I don't feel bad being that fat in
a jiu jitsu game no more why not because
there was a ton of fat Jujitsu guys no
really really and they are tremendous
after a certain level like after they
hit a brown belt yeah they get bigger
like they get bigger and fatter like
with a strong fat yeah and I saw this
one black belt uh pole guard and he
almost ripped the other guy's shoulders
off oh because it's so big he's so badly
three of those pounds he just went
[__] pull them yep you're gonna move
that much weight every day you probably
get stronger it was very interesting to
see them take their top saw I mean I
went to see something else I didn't go
to see that I just went to see a
tournament neon bellies and yeah you
know but plazas and [__] that's it
you see like eight eight fights going on
at once it was six fights matches was
dead oh really Ashton was there the
whole bunch Donald family but they're
all the the Gracies were there I went to
one with Tate in Long Beach yeah that
[__] I mean I was and I appreciate
the Jujitsu line listen when I was a kid
well not when I lived in New York we're
not always there or what's the kid's
name the black kid was dead we hugged we
had a great time my friend he was there
you know when I was a kid not when I
lived in New York City and the karate
with Lauren Joe's father when I lived in
Jersey I got to say three years of my
life you had to go to three things a
weekend with this
karate where I went in Jersey the guy's
name was Kevin Norland or something and
he was a Vietnam vet but he was not all
that remember we talked about him
somebody called in he goes he still
teaches and he wanted you to go to three
things a month you only had one Sunday
off a month or one Saturday
so he would check them off like you
before you sent your application he
would check them off so every month he
went to the Bronx that's what I did guys
before I started smoking dope me and six
idiots like you would get together at
eight in the morning with our karate
geese and we take a bus somewhere and we
take a bus we go to an auditorium with
each Spar not with each other in a
tournament we do forms and then three of
the six would take a gold or a platinum
or whatever the [__] the medals are and
we'd go home once I started smoking pot
I didn't want to be with those guys no
more not that I love her I was just too
embarrassed they didn't get highly uh
Ari all they did was do karate so these
guys didn't understand that world so the
more I got high the more I distanced
myself from those guys which was my
[__]
I would have been a killer if I found
those guys those guys were great guys
but that's what they did and that's this
lifestyle 800 milligrams 200 you know me
I'm always ready to rock and
rollers so we take the Irregulars
and [__] uh
and sell them for 20 or the small 15. I
mean Frankie would get like 12 13 Pairs
and that's the third time we got caught
these dude circled us and said listen
you can't be doing this [__] no more
this is all [__] angle what you could
do is what we'll buy them from us for
five bucks
but me and Frankie in those days used to
drive down there when he was 16 and a
half it's a flea market for the flea
market in Englishtown New Jersey which
was a good [__] hour
and we listened to Bachmann Turner
overdrive that eight track
over and over we're gonna go take care
of business
the same me and him we're gonna go take
care of business it's like a theme song
this was it we were gangsters we'd stop
and get hot dogs I remember we stopped
and got White Castle and at that age I
knew I couldn't eat white cows why
because I got such a bad headache I
couldn't leave the house the rest of the
day what that next Sunday I woke up and
barked I didn't eat White Castle again
until High School too salty maybe yeah
it was too much sodium it was so gross
also gross oh they're delicious they're
awful listen those little white castles
with cheese steamed are you [__]
kidding me we're the worst things in the
world in a Pepsi listen if right now if
right now we drove over to the one and
they are terrible if it is fresh out of
the oven yeah and I mean like take it
out and just throw it into your mouth
what do you think we're gonna do you
think I'm gonna stand for two years but
I'm gonna tell you something people take
them to go what what day is it I'll tell
you what I guarantee you I can be right
next to one yeah and I can get the three
package from Ralphs
did you know that you get the three
packets from Ralph there's a Puerto
Rican that's the same you're saying
that's the same as so what you do is you
take the [__] thing and you take a a
little pie pan and you fill it with like
a half inch of water and put it under it
my friends do it all the time we go over
there we're like where the [__] do you
get these White Castles
I go listen if you listen to the people
at Ralph they say to put them in the
oven that's not the way to do them you
got to steam them the way they do them
and you steam them that's what I'm
saying you think I eat that [__] but
I'll tell you what how to respect for
New York City every time I go to New
York I get two white caps and fries and
I buy a Pepsi am I how we lying leader
I'm not taking a White Castle on 91st
Street you did did we not eat on the
corner like animals outside we saw
homeless the fries are good they have
really good fries you agree with me the
burgers they're garbage Burgers what
they're only for when you're drunk the
burgers oh God see here's the thing it's
it's like as a kid because I didn't have
any kids I didn't even like him as a
[__] kid and I'm telling you as an
adult you know what they're a piece of
America since 19. I want how old is
White Castle 19 [__] 15 or something
like that out of respect you got to go
eat one and you never die they always
said they were horse meat whatever it's
the same [__] they give you and the [__]
I like as a kid that's steak though
that's your mouth what do you always
talk about that's your mafia meat it's
White Castle
1921.20 [__] one they've been serving
food come on give me a [__] breather
it's not the it's not Cuisine it's not
already Morton's it's not like shea
butter it's what it's like
knock your socks off all right the the
burger with the with the fish Patty
in White Castle yeah oh it's just
perfect
it's kosher the whole thing don't worry
about nothing
where the [__] you been doing I don't
call you don't write
last time I saw you you had a bald head
and a leg now you show up with hair yeah
I gotta cut it again [__] find a
broken leg what is it with you you're
like uh you know you're loving life and
I gotta give you that much you don't
give a [__] yeah and it doesn't matter
you're single you have no responsibility
you have an appointment here you got an
apartment there
you got no car you said [__] it you got
a bicycle that's right okay and that's
it probably that's all who gives a [__]
the Sun
yeah
listen man at the end of the week that's
all that matters you're happy yeah
having a good time and you're doing what
you love doing your story comes out
tomorrow
I know
on YouTube the other story
what are you gonna remind me before you
know yeah
I was watching it today
how you feeling I'm good I had a fun day
last week Thursday what did you do I
went to the beach for the first time
ever in L.A did you yeah and uh well I
was going I was just gonna go to Malibu
because I didn't want to fight the
traffic to Santa Monica but
someone told me about Point Doom well
and I went there and it was great
yeah I heard about that it's kind of
scary though because they have really
steep stairs and I was really high so
the stairs were kind of scary but other
than that there's a little water hell
yeah that was the best part I went up
and I went all the way into my head
and [__] yeah I like going all the way
under I haven't done that I haven't done
that in [__] like
15 something years probably how cool was
it it was really cool oh
has everything got all those caves
I don't know they had Surfers they
probably did have caves because it was
like you had to like climb down a
mountain
to get there yeah
but it was so fun a lot of people down
Italy no there was well here's the thing
it's March and it was like a weekday so
maybe maybe they just
didn't have people but there was no one
it was great
you know
listen I love the [__] beach
who doesn't love the [__] Peach he's
just great it's warm
I grew up on a [__] beach
okay I got another great sound effect
what's that that's Sarah the cops the
cops
you're not being a kid in the Summers I
[__] uh
grow up right in Miami I'd go down to
Miami for for three weeks and the last
week my mom would come down and we'd get
a hotel with the family I stayed with
her she was a godmother to the their
daughter and all those you know we'd
stay on the beach for eight days you
know and go out there I love the beach
but it's such a [__] chore when you
live here
it is but it isn't especially if you go
to the 101 to the Malibu because the
Santa Monica is going to be deaf
yeah the four or five would just yeah
there's no way but in the other the best
part about it I didn't say I took my
shirt off I haven't done that ever hell
yeah man
I've never feel it was great I'm so
white but like I was always too I was
always too self-conscious brother good
for you bro [__] it yeah that's a [__]
yeah at the beach at the end of the week
yeah you get a little Sun a little
vitamin D on your titties
there's actually a spot because it got
too cold yeah so I climbed up the
mountain and there's a spot you can just
like look over the water like they have
like a lookout spot and it was great I
just sat there and like rode all day it
was like really fun well I spoke to you
that morning you sounded very
enthusiastic but at the same time you
sounded very uh
like you wanted to go out of your
comfort zone like you were done like you
didn't want to sit around anymore
I like it too much so I'll do it all day
if I could like I would
if I could never leave my house again I
would that'd be fine
but I wanted to try like I live in L.A I
might as well go and then
if you were right like you always told
me to like get some sun and just get out
of the house I I
the house is the best that's why I don't
want to leave the Jeep when you were
down there just stop and get like a fish
burger I wouldn't got a burger at like a
place called fish tacos but no but
that's here's the thing what
I normally wouldn't go to a place like
that and I normally would I don't like
eating alone so I would take it to go
but I stayed and I ended up talking to a
guy and he told me about 0.2 I was gonna
go to a random Beach
so it's like
it's terrible I hate being social but it
worked it did so that's why I'm trying
to do it more I went into the beach in
San Diego this weekend
I went into the water with my crutches
on
my questions
yeah get some water get some water get
on it yeah the water heals it with the
oil you just dig in you just dig in I
fell down a couple times just standing
up in the regular ocean how did you
three legs three legs once those waves
more than one more than you
I was and I had two stars and two of the
red ones it wasn't really anything but I
kept thinking like if I died I was gonna
be like the first person to like get
blamed for weed but it wasn't that like
it was just I I just I didn't I only
went up to like my waist and then I just
ducked under when the waves came dude
it was so much fun
I miss going to the beach a lot
and I was doing it a lot before Mercy
came
me and my wife were going down there
twice a month to the beach remember I
fell and I got a hole in my leg and I
got hit by the rock down there I was
going to the beach a ton
once my daughter came home she gets car
sick either way whether we take the 101
to [__] uh you know the the other way
down Santa Monica with all the curbs you
know you get off where the [__] do you
get on hang up we could do Japan yeah no
no we used to get off uh the 405 to
Sunset then get off and make a right and
go down that that way I guess the
straightest way would be the 405 to the
10. well we used to go to that beach and
then uh both ways she gets sick so we
stopped going
[__] it I love the goddamn Beach I like
you know the Jersey Shore
all that [__] but we were talking about
something that you didn't [__] know
about oh man I just zoned out I know you
did because that's no that hash will
take it to where you need to be that's
from the one I drew that's in you no
that's a [__] edible kick again no
you have a bullhead right you're right
you're right my fault nah what the [__]
whatever it is who gives the [__] what
it is all right sorry what are we
talking about we were talking about you
hurting your leg before the [__] show
oh yeah and we're talking about my
skiing thing a couple weeks ago I worked
with Marin and I was talking about
skiing and dimensions and sizes and the
guy's like wait a second you ski and I
go dog
for [__] four years that was my life
and nobody knew about it
nobody knew that you were scared nobody
I never I got there in April of 83 and
everybody busted my balls they're gonna
ski are you gonna ski you're gonna ski
and my claim to fame was in Jersey one
night my friends took me out
it was midnight skiing at the Playboy
Lodge
this is how old along ago this was Ari
I know what it is to be called Walking
in the [__] uh
Northern New Jersey with the winds off
to Hudson in January getting off a bus
and walking up those three blocks your
ears feel like they're gonna crack
[__] that when I went skiing the first
time with those animals and I got on top
of that mountain that [__] wind hit
me I tapped out I threw the ski stuff
and I told the guy to help me and they
shot me down on the [__] thing you
want to talk about embarrassment doing
with a [__] grandma Coke in my pocket
and they ball in the room and I was like
I'll never skate it's a typical if it
goes through your jacket I didn't
understand how you're gonna go skiing
on ice when it's cold you're gonna fall
and you're gonna [__] bump your head
you know I just didn't feel the logic
but once I moved
to Aspen my friends said why because you
got powder
yeah it's complete it's two different
words yeah the east coast is way worse
the East Coast was garbage like at that
time at that time I didn't know I I
that's what I started on the East Coast
I didn't know what uh good scheme was I
didn't know I had no idea but all I knew
was I didn't like the experience in
Jersey
so here I am in [__] Snowmass Village
November of 83 and I'm surrounded by
people [__] people ask me if I'm
risky and I tell them I'm a [__]
[__] New Yorker at the time
no I don't [__] ski [__] you people
I'm not even gonna watch and one day I
went up there and I went to get a bowl
of chili a bowl of stew at the stew pot
and I walked a long way
and I saw these people zooming by
and I was like wait a second I'm [__]
19. what am I doing with my wife
what am I doing I'm going with Jim and
hitting a bag that's my [__] life and
I go to Aspen and I [__] take classes
or whatever the [__] I'm doing you know
what here's the the deal my neighbor was
a manager at sportkaline
support Cannon's a big time sporting
thing up there and his dad died and he
had to go back so I lent the money and
when he came back he gave me the money
he goes listen
your first ski lesson is on me and all
the equipment
just like that really so December 24th
what
the dude I walked up there December 24th
I hadn't spoken to him since he got him
back and he gave me the cash back like a
man
and I walked in that December 24th and I
said I'm ready to go skiing he goes dog
I'm busy as [__] I can't give you a
lesson but you're getting tightened up
with the best demos I got this is yeah
you go to Indonesia with this this is 34
a piece in a donation you're going to
jail for so long yeah you got like 20
years hey just give them to the people
at the police station take these there
vitamins
those little Chinese people go down in
[__] flames and Indonesia we ready
we're ready this podcast is brought to
you by
hellotushi.com but days are back [__]
portable bidets that fit right in your
bathroom and they work magnificently
deal with it [__] let me
explain something to you it's Father's
Day I know you've looked at your dad
from time to time and said you know what
I could tell my dad's [__] stinks
you're looking at your dad and you go
he's had those pants on for three days
he's a filthy animal but I can't say
nothing because he's my dad but you know
what his [__] must smell like you
know why him and your mom sleep in
separate beds because he's a filthy
[__] animal but let me explain
something to your father's day because
it's coming and you could send them a
hello tushy right to his door go to
hellotushy.com and take a look at those
portable bidets you're gonna love them
you got a 90 day money back guarantee
what is it to it washes your [__]
what do you mean I put him in portable
portable you put it on any toilet that
you want it connects to the to the
tubing and the next thing you know after
you take a little poop yeah let's say
you're feeling down and you want a
little sprinkle in your [__] you sit
down you turn it on and it washes your
little muffler for you just like they do
in Japan the only thing is this is
portable go to hellotushy.com right now
and pressing Church Bam off your wallet
delivered right to your house also the
podcast is brought to you by audit on it
the leader in supplements whether it's
Alpha Brain shroom Tech or shroom Tech
sport go to on it.com right now and
press in church bam I get 10 off also
thank you for listening to the church
kick that meal Lee on a beautiful Monday
morning slinging dick and giving out
Chopsticks Lee syatz here I think Ari
Shafi is here I'm here I'm mostly here
I'm mostly here that was a tremendous
bomb I told you yeah this new weed we're
getting out here there's new weed from
the one I drew Jesus this is killing
[__] all right I tried to send
you postcards it's a warning
don't come back it's too strong now
nobody will have to intelligent [__] you
went away for a long time don't shine
shoes no more this is where you do smoke
out there you would have laughed at it
it was that all brown oh yeah it's just
like sticks of things
depends where some places not much like
10 bucks for like
like a ground up eighth you know like a
shitty looking eighth where'd you get
the best weed at
Vietnam Vietnam Vietnam had good weed uh
yeah one guy had it like California weed
or Vietnam it had been a long time it
had been like two and a half months
already so just way better than anything
I remembered how was the food in Vietnam
pretty good those bought me sandwiches
you would love those just quick [__]
in a little bun like uh like an eight
incher they stuff it they it's like just
fresh super fresh bread a grilled they
got that from the French and the French
invaded them and they just stuff it full
of [__] like what chicken and then like
uh like a little long carrot and some
like hot peppers in there if you want
a little bit it's just there on like you
know Hoagie I guess that would invaded
Vietnam first French the French got out
and then immediately America is like
hell yes we're getting in there because
if you watch Apocalypse Now the red
ducks yeah they add those scenes what
scenes were they having dinner at the
French house and they get into an
argument and the guy tells more the
pressure already gone
you know what man or the French was part
of the house the French it's the
French's house
this is the scene after they go and surf
Charlie don't surf and then they go to
the thing and they see The Playmates
come down the helicopter from there they
go on to the Lagoon
and they go somewhere and the movie
turns a turn you know the Apocalypse Now
when it came out in 79 it was a great
cut it was a three and a half hour movie
yeah but then for the 20th anniversary
or something I don't know exactly they
added that extra hours
some five hours something something if
you want to look it up Lee and there's a
scene when they're in some guy that's
French soldiers and they're having
dinner and they get into an argument and
they explain to the American that you
know
you can't we can't believe what you're
doing now now we already dealt with this
so that's now yeah I forget all yeah
they had like two successive Wars there
the French and they drove out the French
and then immediately Americans moved in
they're like we're gonna take you over
they never attacked anybody they just
they were just there
they called the American war there
and how does Vietnam look today it's all
right Ho Chi Minh was pretty packed
pretty packed yeah motorcycles
everywhere it takes you like 20 minutes
to work at the courage across the street
they just go there's so many of them
hundreds of them
yeah I know he's over overdone like like
you just keep they have districts to go
out farther and farther you [__] you
America no not once they like us now
they like us now that was just an old
government they don't care about them
well are you they don't like the Chinese
anymore are you self uh Korean or or
Vietnamese or am I of Korean or
Vietnamese descent no you just ask me I
just uh is it will you insults or what
should we uh what I'm sorry I don't even
Vietnam I'm sorry Jesus Christ let's
hope what was your question for a second
I was confusing Korea with Vietnam did
you think I was Korean or Vietnamese yes
no no no I thought you I thought you
were in uh Korea not Vietnam oh I get it
I get it what did you find out about
Apocalypse Now 450. that's what it
finished with four hours 50 minutes yeah
for the reduction that's so long yeah
you can't come on you can't do that
no I can't do it I've watched parts of
the read Ducks I can't lie to anybody
I've watched parts of it it's just too
long yeah and I think it takes you
somewhere you don't want to go they've
redone The Godfather they've added all
the scenes back
really like [__] nine hours all three
of them together all three of them
together you see them in chronological
order you see that no no I think it's
the first two and they put all the parts
back
and it comes out if you if it starts at
12 it goes till six or seven o'clock at
night HBO oh and now I think Bobby
didn't Bobby put something out today on
Facebook Bobby Sharon they're releasing
The Godfather for a week remember in
theaters yeah oh that's a week or the
week after
re-releasing The Godfather for a week
for the 45th anniversary I think that's
gonna be the move you know what you know
why you know why because of Godfather
four because they're trying to put a
percent pre-hype for it really yeah
they're trying to get people talking
about Godfather four yeah are they gonna
shoot a gun yeah yeah yeah it's like the
grandson
or something
or like them in like a war with somebody
else I don't know
I mean I think maybe just saw maybe it
was that kid maybe the kid grew up the
boy a dumb boy yeah yeah what if a dummy
got got in like
gotten ahead of the mafia seems like a
comedy then right
I guess that's low-witted son he became
the head of the mafia it always happens
I've thought for a while that they could
I think the movie theaters could survive
on just re-releasing the best of the old
movies and then and just I mean there
are movie theaters that show old movies
but if you just re-release like the best
not every movie but just had like yeah
and you can do and you could do uh like
marathons like if you wanted to do the
all the Godfathers in one row yeah but
just give the new movies a break until
they get a chance to make listen there's
people that are nostalgic about a lot of
movies so what you do is
16 Candles yeah they make fairies let's
get Ferris Bueller yeah sure okay Ferris
Bueller everybody loves Ferris Bueller
you want to re-release Ferris Bueller
you'll get my seven dollars but I'd
rather you add
two or three things
you know two or three scenes that we
didn't see oh yeah something and we
released it in the 32nd anniversary and
I'll pay you the [__] 12 or whatever
the [__] it is Ari yeah I'm just saying
that I don't mind all right those are my
favorite movies I mean everybody's
nostalgic about 16 candles or what's the
other one it is 16 candles with the
Chinese guy yeah they adopt the Chinese
guy [__] he's still her underwear yes
he steals the underwear that's a good
one shows it off with Michael Hall
that's right that's right he had the
party yeah yeah
all those movies are phenomenal you know
The Breakfast Club was just on what did
I watch today
today I watched the second half of
something that I said this never [__]
comes on you know those movies if
there's nothing to do yeah now let me
explain something to you there's some
people who like going to Tarantino State
or the Beverly oh yeah yeah would you
let me ask you something Lee because you
actually go to more movies than myself
and I yeah for sure right I used to
would you go see
one of your favorite old movies with
Paula at the at the uh Starlight well
this is the Skylight ArcLight
and pay the 18 see I want to pay 18 but
here's the thing how much is the arc
like I think Arc light's around that 12
50 13. 15 something like that let's
pretend now let's I'm not even talking
about the godfall let's be fair
let's say uh here's an example just for
kids my age like we we watched Good
Burger a few months ago has a way better
time like that and and that's not a
classic for like a good burger really
but it's a classic for like Stoner like
just for like but I think you could get
away going from like the 70s and 80s
even not even not even the 90s you could
do the 90s if you wanted to but just 70s
and 80s and just because how you always
get on get on mad at me for like not
seeing things like give us a chance to
see it and then because the only reason
tickets are that high is because of
these [__] these uh whatever it's called
the uh studios are making that's where
they make their money so if they just
re-released old movies they could lower
ticket prices because they're not paying
anything to get the movies out there so
they probably end up making more money
because they're not all they have to do
is pay residuals I would like to open up
a movie theater differently like I went
to a movie theater in San Francisco in
1985 re that you would have died yeah
they closed it up or maybe it's still
open it's on the tenderloin it's on the
it's on Haight Ashbury I'm sorry and it
used to be close to the end and I saw a
mask there the movies there and the
little kid not the mask mask 1985 with
Cher when she had the kid that was
really ugly what the [__] up hat you
ever see that no what a default a mask
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Eric
Roberts Eric Roberts so what I had to do
was this movie theater
I don't know how they made money but
this is the deal guys he had a big head
in that movie yeah it was really bad in
real life it was even bigger when he
died this summer and [__] did he really
yeah he died that's something Eric
Roberts no the guy that [__] Eric
Roberts [__] played oh this is what
they had this is why I don't know if you
can make money and be successful first
of all you'd have to put love seats
because people go in twos go wear and
twos to the movie theater
okay so at this movie theater I went to
San Francisco oh yeah in 85 yeah they
just had
23-man couches that look like the
couches in La Jolla oh really all
[__] busted and whatever they redid
them real cool yeah they had ash trays
in there for weed and cigarettes oh they
made popcorn with real butter and they
made homemade chocolate chip cookies not
the [__] like a guy was there packing
the car yeah wow and they would come out
and the bell would ring like a nice girl
nice it would still look like 1950 in
there you could still smell the sperm
from the burlesque days but it didn't
matter
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]